and on the other side of the world
security is a worry for our Navy's fifth
Fleet based in Bahrain a Crackdown on
protest there has taken the lives of at
least three we have more than 4,000
service members there who already have
their hands full keeping an eye on Iran
which is planning to send warships
through the Suz Canal for the first time
in 30 years now as Robert Spencer he's
the director of jihad watch sir we keep
hearing uh they're going to send the
warships through they're not going to
send the warships through whether or not
they send them through or not they've
made a statement have they not oh very
much so Eric absolutely Iran really in
general is making a move right now we
should not understand the protests in
Bahrain in in uh as having anything to
do with anything else but Iran making a
move because Bahrain is 2third Shiite
Iran has long claimed it as a province
of Iran and they are trying now with
these demonstrations to topple the Sunni
regime that has ruled there for quite
some time and install a Shiite one that
will be more compliant with their own
wishes it's the same thing his Bala they
Fund in Lebanon which is also rattling
Sabers now against Israel Syria aided
his and getting a imprisoned his Bala
operative a terrorist out of jail in
Egypt and he appeared at a rally just
yesterday with nasrala the head of
hisbah in Lebanon Syria of course
depends very heavily on Iran Iran is
working in Iraq to create a Shiite
client State there and the Bahrain
demonstrations this uh this attempt or
non- attempt or whatever it is to uh
create an incident at the Suz Canal Iran
is trying to position itself as the
leader of the Islamic world and the
leader of the offensive against the
United States sir allow me I hate to cut
you off I'm sorry guys pull up the the
the map I want to show you a map of of
the region I want to tell you why those
pictures you just saw were so scary
check it out there it is bahin about the
middle to the right side of your screen
right there that little choke point
right there that's called the straight
of Hormuz 20% of the world's oil passes
through that little area right there on
the other side of the of the Persian
Gulf from Bahrain Iran a very very
important Waterway right there go ahead
sir so see they can took that off and
then if they can come around from the
other side with a Muslim Brotherhood
state in Egypt controlling the the Suz
Canal then uh imagine to think the the
consequences could be catastrophic for
the oil supply all right hang in there
sir um Terry Israel what what are they
thinking what are they doing what are
they what are they watching for here
well they've got to feel increasingly
surrounded uh Egypt was uh their only
reliable Ally in the region but it was
also for the United States a reliable
source of intelligence in the region and
so the fact that Egypt is now in in a a
big question mark for everybody is
causing everybody great consternation
and I think that it's Testament to
what's going to continue to happen in
that region with with instability uh
there comes a a sense of desperation and
maybe more risk-taking by dangerous
people you know you know I I kind of
look at this a little different I kind
of look at this like they're playing the
game of cat and mouse to take the
attention away from the protests that
are starting to happen in Iran again and
what's happening in Iran it's catching
on again there this takes all the focus
away from it now you're focused on all
these Navy ships going to go through the
sew Canal the Iranian ships are they
going to go through there and I really
believe Iran is doing something to take
the focus away from what's stirring up
within their own country that's my
belief I thought you said that b there
was a a report out of Iran today and
telling Bahrain to be careful be careful
don't don't cause too many problems in
the area kind of hypocritical on their
part absolutely hypocritical and and I
agreee with Bo this is a game of of
chicken if you will but a but a high
stakes one that you know so much is
involved and here's the other thing
that's interesting to me we talked about
the upheaval the the unrest and the
uncertainty in Egypt okay here's the
tricky part on one hand this is a
product of the fact that this 30-year
dictator that everyone said had to go
right but he was I'm not going to say a
friend but at the same time there was we
don't want to admit that sometimes
dictators even if we're for democracy
across the world across the globe they
provide a degree of stability this is a
product of what happens when you lose
that necessarily so Mr Spencer I found
that the thing I was looking for it says
uh the press release says Iran urges
Bahrain to show restraint meanwhile Iran
they stifled their Uprising their
protesters they killed massive amounts
of them what are they saying here what
what am I not getting well I think that
uh the the key Point comes from the
Iranian press the government controlled
Iranian press at the a aite new news
agency and others inside Iran and what
they have reported consistently is that
the supreme leader the Ayatollah K has
been saying that Iran is the leader of
the Islamic revolution that these uh
Revolutions in various countries are uh
Islamic revolutions that is going that
are going to be the herald of the
creation of a new supranational Islamic
State headed by Iran and he's been
saying this over and over again then
when he turns around and addresses the
protest in his own country he says
they're not Islamic they're enemies of
God and so on and so you know he thinks
he can keep a lid on them while making a
bold move to make Iran a real
geopolitical player as it has not been
for centuries really in the Middle East
World it just goes back to the level of
of instability in the region because
underlying all of these nation states at
war is the war between sunnis and Shia
the Saudis being the the dominant Shia
nation state and the Iranians being the
dominant Sunni so there there's nothing
but bad news coming out of I hate I hate
to be I hate to be the negative one is
going to be a time very soon where our
president's going to have to make a
decision to make a parking lot out of
Iran because they're going to get
nuclear weapons we got to make it we got
to cool them down a little bit to get a
little too up we're going to leave it
there uh on the parking lot out of Iran
I like the
idea say thank you to Robert Spencer
from Jihad watch thank you sir